All right, if that time of the week for audience
questions, you can submit these really however
you want.
Tweet me at [inaudible] the
Pacman, uh, email, Facebook, Twitter mentioned
Twitter already.
Instagram, I don't know.
In any case, uh, every week I answer three
questions.
The first one today is, Hey David, who are
going to be the first democratic candidates
to drop out of the 2020 race.
So the first question is, do you mean prominent
or not?
And if you do, how do you define prominent
versus not prominent?
We've already seen some people drop out.
So former West Virginia, Senator Richard Oh
Jetta, who I interviewed has already dropped
out, dropped out very, very early.
He said he wasn't really able to raise money.
Um, so I guess I'll answer the question as
far as the slightly more well known candidates,
although everybody has a different sense of
who kind of counts because there are all sorts
of different people running as we found out
this week, including with some of the people
that, that we talked to.
So of the people that I would consider relatively
prominent and that, or at least potentially
showing up in polls, although in some polls
they're polling zero, which isn't good.
I don't think Hickenlooper is going to last.
I don't think Kirsten Gillibrand is getting
any traction whatsoever.
And it's really hard to imagine the making
it all the way to the first primaries.
Congressman Tim Ryan, I like the Guy I met
him, interviewed him, uh, at netroots nation
in, uh, New Orleans in August.
Has a lot of great ideas talking about stuff
that a lot of other members of Congress don't
talk about.
Have a hard time seeing how he gets any traction
you're, you're already sort of seeing or maybe
better said, not seeing him anywhere because
he's not getting any traction.
Um, who Leanne Castro entered the race early.
He's getting very traction, but he's at least
getting 3% in some polls and that gets me
to Tulsi.
Gabard Tulsi has a very loud following, but
I continue to see her not getting any traction.
She's pollings zero or one in most polls.
She's polling 1% in a new Emerson national
poll and Andrew Yang, who started as a complete
unknown without even a seat in the House of
Representatives to use as a sort of jumping
off point.
Uh, even gang is polling 3% in this recent
poll compared to Tulsi Gabard polling 1%.
Now, I think that that's one that her followers
will disagree with me on.
They'll say, David, as soon as the debate
start, she's going to rocket up.
She has made the debates.
So it's just a matter of time for Tulsi Gabbard
um, and we'll see.
I mean, I think there's no question Tulsi
is going to last longer than Kirsten Gillibrand,
uh, Hickenlooper and Tim Ryan.
But it's not looking good for Tulsi and this
is not, I'm not giving my opinions here about
who I like and don't like.
Tim Ryan, I really like interviewed him, met
him, very smart guy, very knowledgeable guy,
spoke after the interview with him about economics
and many other issues.
Um, I'm just going by the Poles and by the
media stories that we're starting to see.
Um, and that is a, there, there's no indication
right now that Tulsi has the legs to keep
it going.
Amy Klobuchar also unlikely to last very long.
Jay Inslee seems to be going nowhere.
John Delaney is absolutely going nowhere.
So from the people currently running the ones
with what I see as sort of staying power.
These are not, again, endorsements of who
I like, just people who are getting traction
in a way that is fomenting or building a campaign
that is pulling something at this point in
time.
You've got Bernie, you've got Beto O'Rourke.
Again, I'm not a Beto Fan, but if you look
at the polling and the fundraising, he's doing
well at this point in time.
Kamala Harris, who is not a super interesting
candidate to me.
Then slightly in the kind of half tier down
would be Elizabeth Warren and Pete Budaj edge
has been getting attention and has been rising
in the polls and then further down you see
Cory booker and interestingly as I mentioned
it to Andrew Yang who is polling 3% in this
new Emerson poll that came out earlier this
week.
That is very interesting given that a Gillette
brand is polling zero in that one, John Delaney
pulling one in that Emerson poll and Tulsi
Gabard polling one.
It is very interesting to see that Andrew
Yang now is polling 3% and that was a poll
released before his CNN town hall, uh, which
was on Sunday night.
So those are my thoughts.
Um, uh, in terms of who we're going to see
go very soon, who we are to see, make it all
the way.
And then who I see right now as the top contenders.
And you know, the great thing, I could be
totally wrong because at this point in time,
rarely does the leader ultimately end up being
the nominee.
And everything I said could end up being completely
backwards, which I think would be something
that will a pleasure significantly.
The Tulsi Gabbert followers who are either
not believing or very upset about her zero
to 1% polling in almost every poll that is
outright.
Now let me know what you think.
Where am I wrong?
Where am I right?